depuis ce matin l'assemblée nationale
offre sa façade le temps d'une
exposition au Mariane d'aujourd'hui le
Palais Bourbon devient la dernière étape
de la marche des femmes des cités
Laurent Hakim Yan
moine il y a tout juste 5 ans la Coupe
du monde de football brandissait la
fraternité black blanc beur et puis la
Coupe du Monde terminée la fraternité
s'est un peu fait oublier 5 ans plus
tard l'Assemblée nationale la remet au
goût du jour 14 Marianne black blanche
ber au fronton des photos maton géantes
commenté par les modèles
j'ai le droit de dire belle bah ouais
plutôt bien plutôt réussi mais ça marche
pour les 13 autres filles on a été
plutôt réussi on n a bien tirer le
portrait je pense ni [__] ni soumise 14
jeunes femmes issues des banlieux en
lutte contre les violences matchistes
des cités après leur marche à travers la
France les voici en symbole de la
République ni [__] ni soumise d'accord
mais pourquoi pas un jour député chacune
va décider si elle continue à basculer
dans la politique pour l'instant c'est
pas c'est pas le cas mais moi je le
souhaite je souhaite qu'un jour à
l'Assemblée nationale on a aussi des
femmes qui soient de de différentes
couleurs à en croire le président de
l'Assemblée nationale on pourrait même
envisager une fille des cité comme buste
de Marianne sur la cheminée des mairies
elle a un visage et ce visage il est
éternel c'est le visage de la liberté
c'est le visage de la recherche
d'égalité et c'est le visage de souci de
fraternité alors que elle s'incarne pas
dans une femme elle s'incarne dans
toutes les femmes y compris les femmes
des cités liberté égalité fraternité et
désormais mixité comme symbole de la
République à la veille du 14 juillet
Marianne opère donc une nouvelle
révolution
elle est fonctionnelle